you just found yourself the tales of mr.
collector a limited-edition story
collection from doctor one detainment
mr. Clank woke suddenly as he always did
and looked around blinking the Sun was
still somewhat bright through the wisps
of storm clouds the great city
glittering in the distance as bright and
fresh as new silver mr. Clank stretched
filling the smooth roll of clockworks
along his spine it had been a hard
choice but even a flickering life was
still a life the key turned slowly
tapping out like a second heartbeat a
cool reminder that he was indeed alive
he started walking smiling as the gears
kept perfect time the fields and small
trees passing by in an easy rhythm even
if it had taken some questionable steps
at least he was able to continue to
journey the city was still far off hours
later but mr. Clank wasn't worried he
was making good time and was still able
to take in the scenery the high
mountains the glittering Lake it was all
bathed in a freshness as if seen with
new eyes which in a way might not be far
off
mr. Clank smiled walking to a tall wide
tree leaning against the bark and
watching the leaves drift and flutter
poor mr. red he'd never get to see any
of this maybe mr. Clank could tell him
about it give him a small sample of
these wonders the clicking slowed easing
down as the key spilled so tired now
just a small rest before the road
mr. Clank awoke suddenly as he always
did looking around with a start a hazy
nicotine yellow Sun burns through the
city clouds bathing everything in a hazy
Twilight the city loomed up across a
sprawl of squat dark homes a few small
gardens and thin trees standing out in
the haze mr. Clank stretched feeling a
harsh clicking as the gears in his
shoulders and arms engaged his spine
shuddering hard once before smoothing
out the key clicking time like a
metronome and a military March he
started walking slowly failing his steps
and watching the Holmes wondering why he
chosen this way this path this idea the
thick cogs jutting from his back caught
a cool breeze between the homes chilling
him deeply the crumbled outskirts of the
city were around him
hours later moldering heaps of rusted
metal made mr. Clank shiver and
voluntarily wondering where the Sun was
now time seemed to be passing like the
coppery dust on the streets everything
seeming to carry a kind of crumbling
frailness a timeless age the silvery
Shara's were streaked with rust and soon
the sound of a sec dog barking breaking
the stillness for only a second mr.
Clank sighed failing a shudder in his
chest leaning against a crumbling
doorway mr. Redd had said something but
he couldn't remember mr. Clank was
worried his memory feeling a little
fuzzy now there had been a tree a silver
something he was so tired
his clock works shivering and seizing
with a jolt exhausted he slid down to
rest eyes flickering over the road mr.
Clank awoke suddenly as he always did a
squealing gasp rising from his lips as
his eyes ratcheted open the endless
walls and towers of the city loomed like
the walls of an oubliette a few damaged
and sputtering gas lamps the only light
on the long grimy uneven Street mr.
Clank stretched moaning as the flywheels
and screws refused to catch missing
their sockets several times before
clicking in his twitching sputtering
arms ratcheting down chest piston
wheezing out of sync with the pitot key
he turned his head slowly shivering his
timing gears missed confused about where
he had gone why he had gone there the
thin gray flesh of his face and legs
looked icy
but the squealing of his joints took his
mind from it he hardly noticed the thin
black fluid his feet were leaking as he
started his chittering March hours later
he might have been standing still
mr. Clank felt claustrophobic dandelo
s-- walls seeming to shrink after every
turn mr. Clank ran and a shuddering
lurch unaware of the time sure he was
late for what he wasn't sure the threat
of thoughts scattering as he saw
something pointed him his face a black
fuzzy pet mr. Clank was lost his
clockwork squealing and sticking deep in
his brain an oily bile leaking from his
mouth unnoticed as he panted mr. Redd
was there mr. Redd had been there mr.
Redd was coming
he whimpered in time to the slipping key
refusing to look behind at the squealing
sound far behind him mister clang
tripped and fell skidding into a heap of
oozing garbage lying there to exhaust it
to move this clock works locked tight
bridging a soundless scream then let go
only to lock again moments later mr.
clank whimpered for help or release he
wasn't sure
feeling a dimness seep up from the
cracked road
mr. clank awoke suddenly as he always
did crying a she tears as his eyes
slowly clicked open the twilight was
real the bloated boiling Sun framed
around trash fires and burning oil on
the open plain mr. Clank screamed
Findley trying to cry as his rusted
pitted frame ratcheted up in a squeal of
frozen bolts in the musty haze trying to
grit his teeth against the agony he
found his lower jaw was gone his exposed
teeth dry and brittle with the thick air
the city walls were an unbroken wall
behind him his path from there forgotten
his way forward a stumbling slow motion
shamble among slag burning oil pipes and
shifting trash forward his legs dug in
on worn spines steely points fogging
rust forward
hours later mr. clank lay twitching and
clicking at the edge of the pit night
had fallen like a slimy sheet smothering
vision thought and breath in an oily
tarp time was passing over him like ants
mr. Clank lying like a dead thing
moaning in a raspy squeal because he
watched the searing Sun mr. Redd was
waiting needy missing wishing listening
the words were shards jabbing and
freezing his strip and sputtering gears
Sparks hissed and arched about
stretching and going slack the memory of
breath coming in tortures moaning gasps
the pit
mr. Clank twitched and flexed trying to
get in but his eyes glazed frozen in a
blank stare watching the slow undulation
of the road mr. Clank awoke suddenly as
he always did lidless eyes fixed on the
pulsing walls the blackness was total
and yet he saw his body hissed and
squealed a paralyzed mess brassy orbs
mocking sight from the mass of screws
the rust was gnawing cancer rats in his
skin maggots in his nerves an endless
itching with no arms to scratch the past
before and behind were obscured frozen
eyes fixed on the leaking sore rim flesh
of the ceiling he hated the softest
under him hated the easy sick fluid
dripping and seeping hated the
flexability hated with a mass that had
moved beyond feeling hours later he
dropped like a numb dead stone landing
on a heap of hissing sputtering hoax the
darkness defied even his endless eyes
the vague haunts of rusty crumbling
metal rowing a sea of black pus mr. red
mr. red
read the squealing notes rose in a
croaking monotone he had taken given
that did not happen
there had been silver there had been
gold there is rust
mr. Clank raged strained snapping and
shattering as he flexed out clawing a
helpless rage into the fleshy floor
digging for the bottom for the escape
for the end for the road
mr. Clank awoke suddenly as he always
did and refused to open his eyes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]